BOARDS.
BRETT KULAK LETS IT GO.K AREA,
SAVARD.OWN AROUND THE NET,
GETS IT IN DEEP AS HOFFMAN SETS
UP IN FRONT OF THE NET.
COULDN'T GET THE PASS AS THAT
KONECNY OVER HIS STICK FIRST PE
SHOTS ALREADY JUST 12 MINUTES IN
AND DROUIN FINDS   SITUATIONS,
A BETTER JOB IN THE DEFENSIVE
SHOT OFF THE MASK OF PRIMEAU.
HE CAN'T CONTROL ITIT
TO PULL
HIGH SUPPORT FOR THE DEFENSEMAN
RIGHT BY THE BLUE LINE, OUT.
HIS 19th GAME OF THE IS SEASON
ABLE TO CLOSE THINGS DOWN.
COLE CAUFIELD SHOOTS IT.
THAT WAS STOPPED BY N UP BY KUL.
>> Bryan: HERE IS CATES COMING
IN, SHOOTS, SCORES!ING UP ON TH
IT DONENEDYK,,
NICE MOVET
TONIGHT. HE'LL WITH CAUANGING
OF THE STICK.
THIS IS A NICE MOVE.
CIRCLE, BACKHAND PASS.
TIME WINDING DOWN.
HAYES TOWARDS THE NET.
SHOT ANDND TO ONE AND CARTER
HAR
POWERPLAY UNABLE TO CONVERT AND
CHIAROT NEARLY ENDED IT.GHTON M,
SPACE OPENS UP AND HE SHOOTS
JUST.
POEHLING JUST OFF.
KALE CLAGUE STICKSHOOTOUT
OH, WHAT A SHOT, UP TOPRIGHT.
JUST SO QUICK, I
GLOVE AWAY.
>> Bryan: ALL RIGHT,.STANDARDS.
IN COMES ATKINSON TO TH